she loves playing of loops
both in r
and in music
and she has a looper to layer her voice
and the looper's name is lupita
so everyone please welcome my ire
today i will tell you about my
experience doing analysis
to study the impact of a program for
refugee children using tools in r
before i get started i like to mention
that this analysis has been done in
collaboration with some
really wonderful colleagues mentors and
overall compassionate and ethical humans
jennifer hill larry aber carly tops and
kalinajikali
i'll start by giving you some background
about the project that we were involved
in so that you can have a little bit of
context about our research question and
about the methods that we use
since 2011 about
6.6 million syrians
have led to nearby countries because of
violent conflict
at least
855 000 of them are living as refugees
in lebanon
90
of the syrian refugees who live in
lebanon live on less than three dollars
a day
and around half a million of them are
estimated to be children and youth
so
under these circumstances
it's obviously difficult for refugee
children to have access to school and to
a normal academic development
and those who do get access to public
school face different challenges than
the local children
like
language differences different grade
placement because of previous school
interruptions
and also cultural tensions with the host
communities
so some of the efforts of the global
community involve after-school remedial
programs that take into account the
realities of syrian refugee kids
the international rescue committee
created a partnership with nyu
to implement and to study a remedial
support program for syrian refugees in
lebanon
the remedial program is called healing
classrooms and on top of their academic
development it targets the children's
psychosocial recovery
and it does it with awareness of the
impact that violence and displacement
have in their lives
the original study design involved
randomizing refugee sites to receive
access to the healing classroom
and the data was collected at the start
in the middle and at the end of the
program
but
being randomized to receive access is
not the same thing as receiving the
actual substance of the program
among the children that were offered
access to the healing classroom
attendance ranged from zero to 80 days
and it was all over the place
so hopefully you can already imagine how
bucketing everyone who has given access
as treated
can be a little bit misleading when
you're assessing the potential benefits
of this type of support
they all got different dosages of the
intervention and some of them
are closer in dosage to the control
group than they are to their fellow
treated
our goal was to learn
what can work for these children's
development so
one of our research questions is about
the causal relationship between
attending the program and the children's
reading skills
the sample that we use for this
particular question
involves around 1800 syrian children
from 33 refugee sites that were offered
access to the healing classroom
for about 26 weeks
but when we talk about causal
relationships
a crucial concept is that of
counterfactuals which basically refers
to what would have been
if we were like able to travel back in
time and switch only the amount of
exposure that the child got to the
program
a perfect randomization would provide us
with a good alternative to time travel
but
attendance was voluntary it cannot be
randomized and enforced
and those who were able to attend may
not face the same circumstances of those
who were mostly absent
and when exposure cannot be perfectly
randomized we need stronger assumptions
and we need more resourceful methods
so the first assumption that we needed
to make in cases like this is that we
have measured
all the pre-treatment covariates that
help predict both attendance and the
reading outcomes
a second assumption is that we have
enough children that are alike across
different exposure levels
so we can estimate reasonable
counterfactuals
and that is known as having common
support
another assumption is that the level of
attendance of any one child
should not affect the reading scores of
other children
this assumption by the way would be
necessary even under a perfect
randomization
but the thing is we cannot ensure that
children didn't help each other outside
the classroom
so we have to recognize the possibility
that our estimates may be smaller than
the true impact
lastly there are parametric assumptions
that are implicit in the modeling
approach that each researcher decides to
select
there is always a tacit belief that the
final model we choose is well suited to
capture the true relationships between
the pre-treatment characteristics the
treatment and the outcome
so
bart or bayesian additive regression
trees is one modeling approach that is
well suited to make counterfactual
estimations
which means it's helpful to estimate
causal impacts of treatments that cannot
be perfectly randomized like attendance
like the name suggests it is a tree
based method
so it naturally accounts for
non-linearities
it limits us from making generalizations
from western-based research to syrian
refugee populations
and it allows us to adjust for a very
large number of pre-treatment
characteristics
bart is a back-fitting algorithm that
involves a sum of weak learners it
incorporates a bayesian framework and a
regularization prior and this ensures
that each tree contributes only a small
part to the overall fit
at the same time it provides us with
good tools to quantify uncertainty
bart can estimate the uncertainty of
each counterfactual prediction and it
gives us a framework to assess the
presence of common support for causal
inference
and also when compared against other
causal inference methods it has been
shown to be among the top performers
there are a few packages in r that can
be used to get a bart fit the ones that
i have had experience with
are base three debarts which is written
in c plus plus and it's faster than base
three
and also bart cos which is a wrapper of
d bars that is already tailored for
castle inference
barclays
made our lives easier because it
automatically computes the posterior
distribution
of the specific treatment effect that we
want to get and it also automatically
flags the observations that lack common
support
but bar causes currently focused on
binary treatment variables only
so
for our attendance question we began by
splitting children into a low and a high
attendance group based on the median
attendance
we fit the model with this binary
version of attendance and we let bart
kos flip the treatment assignment
it estimated counterfactuals for each
child and then it computed the posterior
distribution of the average treatment
effect of moving from low to high levels
of attendance
we looked at four different reading
outcomes and we found a significant
effect on two of them of moving from the
low attendance group into the high
attendance group
but not so much for the other two
these estimates by the way
were obtained after addressing the
missing data and they already
incorporate the uncertainty brought in
by that missing data
with a basic approach we get a
distribution of the treatment effect and
not just an estimate point
and
on top of that here i'm showing you how
those distributions can variety across
different possible scenarios
because of the missing data
and the two outcomes that
we could not see in effect for are those
that were most affected by the missing
information
which you can see in the first and last
figures of this slide
but
what if the missing data
wasn't the only reason that we saw
different impacts of attendance for
those two outcomes
because i mean attendance is not binary
in nature
we wondered if there could be more to
the story like
could it have increasing or decreasing
returns on children's learning
so we dove into the world of continuous
treatments
the idea behind it is that we can
estimate a controversial scenario for
different levels of dosage
for each person
if we could travel back in time as
needed
to adjust the dosage level and test how
the outcome changes then we would know
how each person responds to different
dosage levels
but
while we're not time travelers
we can still use bart to estimate those
counterfactuals
once we have estimated the different
counterfactual states for each person
then
averaging everyone's predictions at each
dosage level
allowed us to get what is known as the
average dosage response function
notice that
this function can be different to a
regression-like approach which would use
only the observed states to fit that
curve
the causal drf package in r did a lot of
the heavy lifting for us
and you can estimate the dosage response
function using bart by calling the base
3 package
our results suggest that three of the
outcomes have a positive causal
relationship with attendance
but the dosage level at which the
marginal impact seems to fade
is around 40 days of exposure for two of
the outcomes
but around 20 days for the last outcome
this gave us additional insight of
why
an impact was not showing up before for
this particular outcome since we were
comparing low versus high attendance
using the median split which was 37 days
these results made sense to us
considering that this was
one of the most advanced reading tests
and most of the kids started with very
low reading scores
and also the intervention only lasted 26
weeks
we also made an effort to assess the
proportion of good counterfactuals that
we have at each dosage level
but unfortunately we don't have time to
go into the details of common support
right now but if you're interested in
knowing more please just feel free to
shoot me an email
but there's still one reading outcome
for which we saw no impact at all
and the first thing to point out is that
that particular outcome had a
significant larger amount of missing
data
we decided to do a little bit more
digging about that measure
and we realized a few things
in contrast to the other measures
that one was less detailed
and it provides information of
full proficiency on different types of
reading skills
and it rates students on a very very
blunt five point scale
another thing we realized was that that
measure was implemented independently by
the irc
and its data collection did not follow
the stricter protocols that were used
for the collection of the other measures
and finally we also consider that there
could be some unmeasured causes for not
responding that particular assessment
which could induce bias in our impact
estimate
a good chunk of our manuscript is
actually dedicated to discussing that
just in case you're interested
so
some takeaways
don't get too confident just because
there was some randomization in your
study
randomization can
it can go wrong sometimes especially
with vulnerable populations
and
the answers that you can get when
looking at a randomized treatment are
not always the most meaningful ones
especially if you want to learn about
the substance of a program
so think about whether you're making
valid comparisons for causal inference
because in social studies if you ask the
tough questions you will often need
additional tools to answer your
questions causally
well some of the tools in r that i found
useful are debarts
bard costs and causal drf
understanding the assumptions that you
are making
and
being transparent about them is very
important
and also try to recognize the pitfalls
of your data i know it's uncomfortable
but
missing data is
pretty much unavoidable especially with
vulnerable and migrant populations
so make an effort
both to prevent it and to address it
you won't really know just how much it
matters unless you actually
assess how different your results can be
under different scenarios
and missing data can have different
implications depending on each outcome
and on each research question
how refined or how rough a measure is
has important repercussions in its
ability to capture moderate impacts
so it's always a good idea to get the
input from a psychometrician and from
content experts at some point of your
project
and lastly
without data quality
your models have nothing to stand on no
matter how fancy they are
so make sure to invest in data
collection and data verification
protocols and make sure that they are
well suited for the population that
you're studying
and that's it thank you for listening
and please feel free to shoot me an
email if you have any questions
[Music]
a random fire turn your paper surveys
[Music]
thinking can sometimes be rough and make
you causal inference will mess with your
thoughts
you